so you actually do think that like the
biological imperative sort of molded you
to kind of go away from that a little
bit yeah I mean I grew up in a very
traditional household my mom took care
of the household and my dad went out and
worked full-time like he brought in
income so I grew up very very
traditional minded so when I decided to
go down the feminist route and I didn't
even know that that's what I was doing
and I think that that's the biggest trap
or the the biggest thing that women
don't understand is that it's not like
you choose to be a feminist like I think
the media and social media and you know
TV all of that stuff plays a huge impact
on us as women like growing up and yeah
I just you know I don't think that women
necessarily walk into it and be like
yeah I'm gonna be like I'm gonna hate
men